Build your own alternative
to Twitter Bootstrap,
and David DeSandro teaches
you physics in five minutes.
I'm Rob Dodson.
This is LazyWeb.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
What are the benefits of
designing your own component
sets?
Alex Sexton covers the virtues
of building your own UI library
instead of using the de
facto, Twitter Bootstrap.
The talk explores tools like
rework and suit for CSS,
and clever techniques
for unit testing UIs
without requiring
Selenium's WebDriver.
If you're a UI developer,
you're guaranteed
to learn something new.
David DeSandro demystifies
the power of physics
by building a simple carousel.
Using basic functions
for velocity, friction,
and acceleration,
DeSandro demonstrates
how we can make simple
objects on screen emulate what
our crazy monkey paws are
used to from the real world.
At a little over
five minutes, it's
an easy primer for anyone
interested in building
lifelike animations.
David East gives an
early look and crash
course in Angular 2 Forms.
The talk covers the basics
of working with Angular 2,
and explains how to the
write controls and validators
as building blocks for Forms.
It also delves into the
topic of writing quick DOM
independent tests.
There's a live coding
tutorial at the end
if you want to bust out your
Text Editor and follow along.
Notifying you of changes
to Notifications.
Push notifications are getting
more powerful with the ability
to associate a data object
with a notification,
and the new Get Notifications
method which allows developers
to collapse a list
of notifications
into a single unread
messages item.
To find out more about
changes to Notifications,
you can check out this
article by Matt Gaunt
over on HTML5 Rocks.
Umaar Hansa demonstrates a cool
new feature of the Chrome Dev
Tools that lets you preview the
value of JavaScript variables
in line as you debug.
The feature works
with minified scripts,
if you pretty print them, and
is available in Chrome Stable.
To find more Dev Tools tips, you
can subscribe to his newsletter
over at Dev Tips Daily.
That's it for this week, folks.
Take a deep breath,
enjoy the visuals.
And to all you lazy webbers
out there, thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]